hey what's up guys my name is jono
welcome back to my game engine series
day three of game engine series week and
today we're gonna be all about style
which let's be honest this whole series
is always about that anyway
but we're finally going to be taking
some time to polish up
our hazelnut editor and make it look as
beautiful as possible
so over yesterday's live stream i
believe me and the stream basically had
a little bit of a chat and we decided
we played around with some colors and we
decided what the theme would be for
hazelnut and this is going to be like
the default kind of a dark theme
obviously it's possible to just go into
the source code and change everything
yourself and make some weird pink
colorful rainbow theme if you really
want to
but in terms of what hazel is going to
ship with we're going to have like a
dark theme and a light theme light theme
will do away later because it's low
priority but today we're going to be
talking about how we can implement a
nice looking dark theme
with some nice beautiful colors and a
good kind of color palette
some better usability features as well
such as having like the entire
kind of header of each component and
also each entity in the scene hierarchy
clickable because at the moment you
actually have to click over the label
and it's a bit annoying
and we'll also be uh using a much more
beautiful font
so without further ado let's dive into
the code and take a look at how this is
all gonna work so as mentioned
um i have already written this code uh
this is um
in fact let me show you guys how i how i
operate because i know that a few people
i think were asking
about you know what exactly it is that i
do here on my special
super secret secondary monitor um i have
a patch
this is called a patch file um basically
what this
is is instead of committing my changes
when i modify it i can save them as a
patch and then i can revert everything
else
and this is basically the code that i
have written and these are pretty much
all the changes that i'm now going to
implement in front of you guys whilst
also explaining
what i'm doing so that's kind of the
idea this is basically all the code is
going in
and obviously if i come up with some
stuff on the spot that i feel
like doing then well i'll do that as
well but usually it's pretty much just
whatever's in the patch
and that's the beauty of this um the
point that i uh well that i can work out
this stuff on a live stream
and take my time because this took hours
honestly to tweak all of these colors
and get them perfect
took hours and having to do that in
front of you guys on this video
would be a lot of pressure and also i
think fairly boring to watch so we can
be a lot more
condensed here if we want to which we do
so let's dive into this the first thing
i want to talk about is the font and in
fact the first thing
really the first thing that i want to do
is actually open up this editor to just
have a look at what it looks like
so this font is fairly rubbish
i don't really like it i mean i don't
want to call it rubbish because some
poor person probably made this font and
they're probably not poor but
anyway the point is it's a fine font
it's like the i'm going default font
it's very simple it's monospaced it
looks kind of all
you know programmy i don't want this i
want to have more of a normal font like
visual studio as font
right so the font for visual studio ui
and all of that stuff
we want to have something just a little
bit nicer a little bit more aesthetic
you know
um aside from the font though let's talk
about this other
kind of styling uh stuff that we
probably don't want to have so first of
all
these kind of blue panels i'm not hugely
into that i want to have more of like a
monochrome kind of feel
we can have like a little bit of color
um i want to change this background so
it's a little bit more
i don't know about if it's going to be
darker or not but i want to add a touch
of blue into it like a very very
uh low amount of blue there just to give
it a little bit of that you know spice
um if we click on one of these we can
see what this looks like
this to me is the worst part though this
looks like a disaster i mean
we've got like the trend the beautiful
transform component but first of all
it's very
unclear what is what like you can see
that we've got a transform component
sure but
there's no kind of i guess frame around
this
header here so if we hover our mouse
over it we can see the kind of extent of
it
but we have to actually be hovering over
the label we can't collapse it by
hovering here
these buttons as well like you know this
kind of overlaps the button you can see
the different sizes
there's no padding really between the
like the sprite renderer and then the
end of this scale thing so it looks a
bit weird
the add component button is just
misaligned over here so what we're going
to do is we're going to pop this add
component button over here into the top
right corner because i think it looks
good there
tag i mean we don't need a label for
this tag it's pretty obvious that this
is the name
and it's pretty obvious that it's a text
field that you can modify
i also want to change the background
colors of all of these
things here and then finally one of the
things that i also want to do
is um set a minimum size for these
panels so you can see that at the moment
we can make them this small
now realistically probably wouldn't make
them this small but even if they're this
small
you can see that nothing really fits it
just looks kind of bad
and like i don't really like that i
think there should be a minimum size
that'll be maybe about this much
and then we can obviously apply that to
potentially all the panels
that are inside this entire dock space
so that is the plan
that's what we're gonna do let's start
off with the font
so as i mentioned uh i have um
already picked a font and i've decided
all this for the stream but basically if
we take a look at
google fonts which is a really good
place where you can just test out
different fonts
there's a lot of different fonts here
that you can check out i think they're
pretty much all apache license which
means that as long as you like you know
ship the license with the software it's
fine um
and yeah i mean you could spend a long
time here looking through all the fonts
but the one that i really like is
called open sans so if we click on open
sounds we can also download it this is
also available on github if you prefer
you can download it from there
it doesn't really matter so i'm going to
download this i've actually already
downloaded it before but doesn't matter
download it again for you guys we'll
grab all of the files in here including
the license and we want to put them
somewhere
so if i go into assets inside the
hazelnut
project here i'm going to go into a new
folder actually that i'll call
fonts and then we'll call this open sans
and then inside here i'll paste
everything okay so now we have all of
these font files
now using them with imgui is extremely
easy if we go into our imgui layer all
we really need to do
is add the font so and and set the
default font to be that font
so over here inside style or in fact
it's it's in
io if we if we go i o fonts let me zoom
in for you guys
so i o fonts and then add
font from file ttf we just need to give
the
file path which is assets fonts and then
let's pick a font so we're going to use
the i guess we'll use the regular one
for regular things and then the size
that i liked was 18
okay that's it that's now been added
let's do dot
that's not been added this actually
returns an iron font so what we can do
is just directly
set the default font or font default
uh equal to that now that's
like pretty much all we need to set the
font to that font so let's
launch this and see what it looks like
it looks like an error
uh asset fonts open sound uh i forgot
open sams
there you go
and there you go suddenly this looks
really nice i think and
we're obviously using a different font
looks a bit more like a program and not
like a little i am gui
uh widget uh which is good and um
yeah that's it now while we're in the
excuse me while we're on the topic of
fonts let's talk about
these things right they're kind of
looking thin and i want them to look
kind of thick
so what i'm going to do is use a bold
font uh for
these kind of x y and z just because i
think it looks nice right
so what we'll do is we'll also add a
bold font now how are we going to manage
more than one font you ask well it's not
really a huge problem
what i'm going to do is uh you know
obviously uh
load the other font like like a normal
person
so let's go and load um open sans bold i
could have
just let's just type the word world uh
except what i want to do now right is
obviously like the way that the fonts
are stored if you actually look at the
way that the fonts are stored um
inside iron font atlas there's actually
another uh
little uh field here remember called
fonts
which is an i'm a vector of iron font
pointers
so inside here we basically have all the
fonts so font zero is kind of like the
first font and then we add this one
essentially as as font
one i guess they're stored in order so
if we remember that
the last font in this collection is the
regular font right that's our default
font
then we can say that the first one is on
number zero
is bold you probably want realistically
a slightly better
system for managing this like in in
other words instead of having to keep
track of the fact that the first font
inside the collection is our bold one
which is kind of dodgy especially if we
add more fonts later
you probably want to just have like some
kind of font library maybe yourself or
build something on top of imgui so you
can get them by name or by like some
kind of enum or
i'm not sure it's up to you i'm going to
leave it as is because it's not a big
deal
and we only have two fonts for now so
what i'll do is inside the scene
hierarchy panel if we go to drawback 3
control
all i'm gonna do is first of all i want
to retrieve
the uh font right so um
we need to get access to all the fonts
so i'll do i am gui
i o i o equals i'm going get i o so this
gets us
our font data that we want i'll do
autobot
auto bold font equals io
fonts and then fonts zero right that's
the first one so one would be
the regular one our default font and
zero of course being the bold one
and then it's as simple as just pushing
the font so whenever i lay
whenever i render this button right the
x button for example i just want to do i
am gui push font
bold font and then when i'm done with it
i pop it
now you can see why first of all i want
to make this a function this whole
uh control but also um why it's probably
a good idea to make some kind of library
from i'm gui
that actually has a lot of the kind of
um you know
standard kind of ui controls that you're
going to use because
you know it can be very verbose but it's
not even
about the fact that maybe you don't want
that much code and it's too verbose and
it's hard to read it's not even about
that it's about the fact that
if you obviously copy and paste similar
groups of code and you don't define a
proper style for your ui
you're going to wind up with little
inconsistencies because there might be
an area where you accidentally set the
padding or the spacing to
like two instead of three or four and
then suddenly
things don't quite look right and it's
very difficult to go on and find it
whereas if you have a nice library that
has like a
certain style defined very clearly and
then you have to reuse your own
library's
controls and constraints and all that
stuff then obviously it leads to
something
a bit more consistent more bug free and
just something that's just easier to
work with which is always good okay
let's test that out while i drink some
water
very hot day today
surprising all right um
so yeah there you go x y z look
bold i think that looks a lot better
than what it did before a little bit of
a subtle change obviously
but i think it looks nice okay the next
thing that i want to do
is address these silly like
header things that look terrible and
possibly the button as well
so as you can see if i'm going over all
of these entities here and selecting
them
i can't select them over here right that
actually deselects everything
i want this to be the entire width
luckily that's
very easy to do in i'm gui it's actually
just
one little flag for our tree node so let
me find where we do our scene hierarchy
which is draw entity node
um we have our flags here what i want to
do is to the flags i want to add another
flag i'll just do it on a different line
so it's not like you know overwhelmingly
complicated here and it's going to be
called
i'm going tree node flags span available
with okay simple as that so what that
will do is now basically span the entire
available width
and i can now as you can see select it
like that
really easy right whereas before it was
kind of like this
because we haven't added it to this one
yet see so that's the difference i think
that looks a lot better
and it's not even a looks thing it's
more of a usability thing as well
so we'll also uh this has its own kind
of flags we'll also add it to this
did that that is kind of temporary code
because you know that's kind of like
before we have
parenting properly working we just have
this like little weird trino that has
the same name as the other one and it's
just like simulating that
but we'll add it there for fun just so
that we don't forget to add it to
our actual um you know parented things
so now you can see all of these
are done properly okay so we want to do
the same thing obviously to
the um to all of our
components now this brings me to my next
point
the whole component situation
it's getting a little bit out of hand
right i mean it's not
that bad yet but if you look at sprite
renderer component which by the way
might i add is the only component that
actually has a proper plus button
that can actually remove the component
if you look at this
look at this little blob of code right
you might see a problem
it's not really a huge problem but it is
a problem and the problem is that
exactly two lines two lines which could
actually be in fact one line
of code are actually specific to the
spry renderer component
and that's literally this the whole
sprite renderer component the whole ui
for it
is just this one little color edit
control that's
all that we see there the rest of this
is
just basically boilerplate code that is
that should be reused for
every single other component so when you
have what looks like about 30 lines of
code
and one line of that is is all you need
for the entire component
it's probably time to maybe write your
code a bit differently
which is what we're going to do so what
we'll be doing is writing another little
static function that you guys love
called draw component now this is going
to obviously be a template
um with the component type and also uh
i'm going to make a little another um
template here called ui function right
or another template parameter i should
say which is going to be our ui function
so we're going to have a label for the
ui control
because um if we look at if we look at
this
right we like what what out of all of
this code
needs to be different per component the
type
that's what our template type name t is
it's the component type
we could probably name it component type
but for me t is fine
um and then also the name sprite
renderer
right those two things everything else
like the frame padding this plus button
to open component settings and be able
to remove the component
all of that you can see is obviously
specific to the sprite render component
which is our t
template argument now but everything
else is the same across all components
now whether or not we have a remove
component can also be
kind of unique uh because obviously like
the transform component you shouldn't be
able to remove a transform component
um i mean maybe we will allow that i'm
not sure
but ultimately you could either pass
that in as a boolean or maybe even have
an
additional lambda that we can take in
that will specify
like what is in exactly inside this
component settings menu
because what we're going to do is
basically copy and paste
all of this code well excuse me
[Music]
something over my words here i'm too
excited about this lambda stuff and like
this kind of drawing component function
what we're going gonna do here is
uh take all of this code put it into our
draw component function
and then the one line of code that we
need which is the color edit for
we're going to take that in as a lambda
so that way
what we can do is basically specify a
function that will draw our component ui
and then we also have a parameter there
where we can drop in any custom ui code
that we want
anything and that's how it's obviously
going to work for something like the
camera component which has a lot more
code
so going back up to the top i'm going to
um
where is this not to the top here it is
draw component so we'll have to take in
a name
right um we'll have to take in the
current entity
because we need to be able to like
access certain things from the entity
potentially as well as remove the
component from the entity
so we need to be aware of what entities
component we're actually rendering here
or we're drawing and then finally the ui
function
okay that's what our draw component
function looks like so if we go back
down here
into the um uh into our
original like spray render component
let's just copy this entire blob here
and uh going back up to i keep losing it
going back up to here
let's paste it in and now sprite render
component obviously becomes
t so we need to make sure that
everywhere we see spriter under a
component which i think is two more
places we replace it with t uh
name is what our label becomes so name
dot c string
and then finally instead of calling this
kind of color edit
you know whatever we're going to
actually call
a ui function
right oh sorry it's just called function
i'll call it ui function
ui function and then we can optionally
optionally take in a parameter we can do
whatever we want here it's really i mean
it is a lambda but we're just taking it
as a template so it generally could be
anything
you just have to make sure that it
executes with one parameter that's going
to be correct here
we're going to take in the actual
component right so we have
a entity get component and this is kind
of like our
um uh like
i guess it's our component which i'm
gonna
change a little bit i'm actually gonna
probably so we have the empty component
let's bring this up here and i'll call
this component so that the whole
function has access to it and then this
component is what we'll pass
in so that that just saves us having to
you know retrieve the component from the
nc or anything like that since we've
already kind of got it here
and we're inside this you know function
that's supposed to be drawing it
we'll do that so there we go that's it
that is it you can see how little code
we actually needed to change to adapt
this
to be basically modular for everything
else so or generic i should say for
everything else so basically
if we compare the before and after draw
component
sprite renderer component now we need to
give it a name which is going to be
sprite renderer
like that needs to take in the entity as
well and then finally our lambda which
is going to take in a component
our renderer component and i'll just
drop it down here so that it's a little
bit cleaner
and it's literally just going to do this
one line of code right slc is replaced
with component
that's it this is the before and this is
the after
how nice is that and the even nicer part
is that for something more complicated
like this camera component right
the actual stuff that we need is
basically
from this line onwards so if we grab all
of this code
right um and then write a draw component
function for our camera component
uh then okay let's see so camera entity
and then auto components
let's drop that down here okay
uh camera component is just replaced
with component you could call a camera
component but i'm just going to be a
little bit
cleaner here um i guess that's
it no surely not all right so we had it
here as well
and here okay and that's it
so we still have all of our ui code
obviously because this is the the stuff
that's specific to our camera component
but we don't care about anything else
because everything else should be
generic
every single component kind of the
header and you know the remove component
button should all be identical so we
don't need to repeat that code
so all of this goes bye-bye
and then finally the transform component
which again is a bit of a special case
because it doesn't have a remove thing
but it doesn't matter we don't really
care about that
let's copy this once again
um i will add a transform component over
here
and transform
um and
stop fighting mutual studio and then
we'll grab
all of these draw vector3 controls
tc just becomes component
like that and i think that's it
all right trina flax doesn't need to be
here either so
let's uh oh and also we have the tag
component but that really is a special
case i mean that's like you know an
input text and it doesn't have like a
proper header it's
rendered differently because it's
obviously not really like a real
component like a real modular component
like
the rest of our components are okay
so yes veg lobster i do remember the
high dpi
uh request thing i will get to that um
okay so tree node flags uh we deleted
that didn't we
um wait no this doesn't need to be here
so we just have our draw components now
if we collapse these they're nice and
simple look like
that great
let's just control f7 that file to make
sure everything compiles inside this
file
it does not because yes we did delete
our tree node flags
i don't even remember what they are
let's quickly undo
and get back to it because i remember i
deleted it recently there it is
i'll copy that and then redo everything
um and then we'll just paste them up
here
but yeah okay good let's take a look
at this so we should have the same
result as before obviously
but now with the added uh bonus of
having way less code there we go right
now everything has the little plus you
can see we can remove our sprite
renderer component that should work fine
we can even remove the transform
component and it should work fine okay
everything is good no matter what
component we have we have this little
plus button that doesn't work properly
we'll fix all this stuff today
um but that is the gist of it okay
really cool now let's talk about the
whole kind of header and what other tree
node flags we may want
because turns out we want quite a lot so
aside from default open
we want something called
um framed right what this is going to do
is actually provide a frame for our
entire header
and that's going to be really nice so if
we launch that we should be able to see
what that looks like
we also wanted to respect frame padding
and then also span
the available width like we did with the
other thing so you can see now this is
like kind of a full
uh a full kind of like the header
actually has like a background color
which is nice
um so let's do frames
we might not even need span available
width but let's do it anyway
span available width and then i also
want
we have our overlap and i'll also add
the frame padding
so that way it's just gonna um take into
account the frame padding by the way one
of the ways that i discovered all these
flags
is not simply just by going through all
this because this is kind of
i don't know there are comments but it
is a little bit difficult to read
is um simply going to the trinode ex
function
trino behavior and then just seeing what
it does so like for example
you can see padding is calculated based
on whether or not
this flag is present if this flag is
present it will use style frame padding
otherwise it will use some other
calculation right
so that's kind of um i mean it's going
to take into account some other things
as well
so just know that like one of the best
ways that i've found
over this game engine series week to
kind of get to know i'm going better is
just by reading the source code right so
you can see like again with this
display frame the frame kind of
in fact how do we even do that display
frame so display frame will work if
framed is present if it's not then it's
not going to work
but then there's also like you know span
available width and span full width and
some other things
to let you interact with it for example
so
yeah just a few different things that um
you might not pick up from i'm going
just by writing comments and by reading
the header files but if you look at the
implementation
it's not too difficult to find out what
else you can actually do with it
so if we launch this yeah i feel like if
we have framed we probably don't need
span
available with um and you can actually i
think we
you can see that let's go back quickly
um so
uh yeah so
um if so if display frame is false and
flags and one of these uh is present
yeah so this actually has to be present
actually because if this isn't present
then it's to be zero and they're not
going to be both
true so i guess you it does need to be
present for interaction but anyway point
is
reading the source code a plus plus
really good way to actually uh figure
out how you want to do something and how
like certain
paddings and bounding boxes are
calculated because i've had to do a lot
of that
over these past few days of styling
okay so um yeah did we launch this
uh yeah so this now looks pretty good um
we have our plus button that looks
terrible let's
figure out what we can actually do with
the plus button to make it look a little
bit better
so i think what i did um so we've got
our frame padding that's why we enabled
this like frame padding uh
flag here so the next thing that i did
was um so actually before open after i
pushed the
frame padding um
i figured out the line height
so float line height is g i am gui
font font size this is just
a better way of doing this because you
can actually calculate instead of hard
coding it style frame padding
dot y times two
now this is a pretty generic padding
calculation
um i think i'm gooey actually even has
comments about this but if you
if you again if you dive through the
source code you can see how it
calculates certain things
this is needed for us to work out the
actual height of the button and the size
of the button
um so we'll need that we'll need that in
a minute in a minute and it probably
doesn't have to happen like here exactly
um but you do have to do it after you
set the frame
so then we'll add a separator just to
keep everything nicely organized um
and then we do our tree note open thing
which we
um did and then i'll pop the style var
over here and then on same line instead
of advancing get window with minus 25
we're actually going to advance by
um we'll say i'm gui get content
uh region available
right yes dot x minus the line height
times 0.5 so half of the line height so
this is us basically
seeing what the rest of the content
available region is
the reason we use this not the window
size is because i found that using the
window size doesn't take into account
the scroll bar
so if the scroll bar appears we
obviously want to move everything to the
left otherwise it'll be behind the
scroll bar potentially and then we'll
the scroll bar will obscure our button
so we can get the content region
available x which is
better and then we'll subtract half of
the line height
just to get it into the perfect uh spot
here
um okay and then finally when we draw
our button
we can just draw it as line height by
line height
and i think that should already look
pretty good so let's
hit f5 and see if our plus buttons look
beautiful now obviously we still need to
play with the colors but
um almost beautiful they look a little
bit too
too far the other way i wonder what that
is
maybe that's to do with uh certain other
things that we haven't set yet
um but we did make that like the
separator i didn't look at the separator
that's all right um what i do
line height times point five oh it's
looking uh
that does in fact look like what i did
so i did i also did push item width
that might be why so
one other thing that i did was
inside draw components no but that was
in a different place oh that was the add
component button never mind
okay hmm
yeah that should have put a button into
the right
spot i wonder why
that didn't work font size frame padding
y
times two content
oh sorry um we need the content region
available
before we actually
start the control stuff so what what
this will do
uh so let's move this over here
basically
if we get the content region available
here obviously the content region that's
available
has decreased because we've just
rendered a trianodx so
or a tree node so we need to actually
get the
full width of the content region
available before we start adding widgets
to it because as we add more widgets to
the same line
obviously that's going to decrease so
this should now be perfect
all right there we go you can see that
it's perfectly at the end and more
importantly if i kind of make a little
room here so there's a scroll bar you
can see it all shifts to the left
which is perfect and exactly what we
want okay cool so those buttons
are a plus plus now um i guess the next
thing we can do is probably move that
add component button right
so what did i end up doing for that so
uh the add component button
at the moment i think we're doing it
here
add component
okay here it is oh and we also need to
fix a bug where um
what this is supposed to do is only give
you the list of components that you
don't already have so that you can add
those
because at the moment you can add you
know a camera component twice which is
just going to crash
with an asset inside and
so we'll draw the components here i
think that's what i did
and then what we'll do is uh if i find
this um
because i want to get this right
obviously
unfortunately i had it before but i lost
everything all right here we go
um so what i'll do is right after we
draw the
right after we draw the um
tag component which is up here i'll do
i'm going same line
so that we continue on we'll push item
width
minus one which should basically take up
the rest of the width as far as i'm
aware because i'll go
the width all the way to the right
border minus one um
and then we'll basically paste all this
stuff so we have our component now and
then
we can um there's always flies flying
around here it's really annoying because
we've got like a plant over there
worst anyway uh and then we just do this
i think as usual so let's just
take a look at this and make sure it's
all good we probably need to pop item
words as well oops
pop item width
uh and then yeah so there we go so we
now have an add component button uh
let's get rid of the tag because that's
annoying and it's taking up space
i'll just add a little hash to hide it
and now we have a much nicer looking add
component button
that we can use to add a component
now i also want to make the size a bit
different because i don't want the
minimum size to be too small so
i'm going doesn't actually explicitly
allow you to set size constraints for
docked panels as far as i'm aware
uh that doesn't exist so a little
workaround that i found for that
is basically um
[Music]
setting the size setting the entire
minimum window size just
for this dock space right so the way
that we can do that is
we'll get the style i'm going
style
equals i am gooey get style
style dot window minimum size
equals and we'll set it to 370 right for
the x so you can't make a window
less so if if the window is docked it
has to be at least 370 pixels wide which
i found is the perfect amount
for our properties panel and then we'll
reset it back to what it was which was
32.
if you were really cool i guess you
could probably get this first
so like um min win size
you could probably get this and then
reset it back to that that way if we
change it later we don't have to worry
about
setting it here as well um and then 370
is what it's going to be and then for
the rest of our windows it will be fine
so let's check that out
ideally what i'm going would do is
probably take into account
the maximum minimum size of all of the
windows that we have here and whatever
that highest number is that becomes the
new minimum for all of the windows that
are in the panel
but they don't do that so and that's
probably what i would do um
in the future maybe i'll even add that
change into our fork of i'm gui
uh if we kind of uh get there but
there's other stuff that i want to do
before that so now you can see i can't
make the panel
less than um the minimum width
same for this one and same for the
viewport so that's nice because we have
a nice little balance for everything
but if we do take this out then i can
make it
the minimum width which is 32 by 32 okay
so that works as expected when you dock
it it doesn't immediately snap like that
but then you can resize and you can't
size it back so that's also a little bit
of a
thing that you can do okay cool so there
we go now that does
uh kind of limit us a little bit because
if we launch this you can see that it's
kind of
um there's not much space here really if
i move this back to the way it is
it doesn't look like there's much space
that is because we're launching and that
doesn't actually look perfect maybe our
style will change a little bit odds
because of the um
scroll bar but anyway um you can see
that's pretty much the perfect amount
here if we don't have a scroll bar
uh but anyway um what was i saying yeah
so
there's not much space here so i think
what i'll do and this really should be
exposed somewhere else but i might set
the default width and height
to be 600 1600 by 900 i think that's a
probably more
accurate size i mean hazel dev just
launches full-on like maximized full
screen
um so i think that this is probably okay
and you can see that it provides plenty
of space here
for us to actually uh work with if we
want to work windowed and not full
screen which would be kind of weird
i think that working full screen is
probably what you want and you can see
that we have
definitely have plenty of size
definitely have plenty of space if we
um work on something like this okay
how much time do we have left 35 minutes
wow this is taking a while
haven't done the colors yet let me just
slap in the colors because there's
really not much to it and it's kind of
the last thing that i want to do
so the way that you can set your colors
in i am gui
is pretty easy um if we go to i am gui
layer
then we are actually already kind of
setting some certain colors but
basically
what you can do is um set dark
theme colors i'm just going to make a
little function for this
uh i guess i'll make it a member
function instead of a static one
because we might want we might um want
to
maybe i'll make it public we might want
to like
uh expose that later to the ui so we can
flip between light theme and dark theme
um so let's maybe implement
this i'll just do this whoops through
visual assist
okay and now uh we'll get the style
which is like this and in fact
i think it's just style.colors so dot
colors
and what is that exactly it's probably a
i am veg4
okay sure so we have
the colors and then now i just need to
set certain colors
so obviously i'm not going to pretend
that i don't have them in front of me
i'm just going to copy and paste them in
hopefully you guys will forgive me for
that and i'll get rid of these pluses
from the patch
turns out i wasn't as cool i was cool
enough to use it this way so i'll have
to quickly
adjust like all of this but basically
these are the colors that i've
worked out over the course of probably
an hour or two during the stream i think
they look pretty good
and they're gonna be our um
default colors for the time being and of
course if there's an issue with
something
yeah i think this one i wasn't sure this
one was so i just set it to pink
just so that if it would show up i would
um see it but in all seriousness let's
uh probably replace that with something
that at least isn't going to look
terrible
and now you are about to see the new
hazelnut there it is that's what it
looks like
okay so we have um
if we kind of collapse this we have uh
different like tab highlights and
different
tab colors based on what viewport is
currently active as well
i left this thing as blue and also i
think the other thing that still is blue
because we haven't changed it from the
default i like check boxes so if
checkboxes are on
you can see they still appear blue but
that looks kind of nice so i've left it
as is
anyway there you go that's what hazelnut
looks like now let me know what you
think of this new
theme this is how the kind of components
look we can remove that component and
then add
a new component i haven't changed the
background of this nor the
file menu just yet i'm not sure even
what to set it to we'll see
this is obviously subject to change as
we go along with this
but i think it looks pretty cool um
and yeah that's what our theme
looks like so you can obviously check
this out and clone this from github and
take a look at it on your own computer
and let me know what you think of the
theme because i i think it's pretty cool
anyway that is going to wrap up this
episode
i'll probably tackle high dpi changes
and all that stuff
possibly next time um
or i think what i'll actually end up
doing is like a bit of a maintenance
episode
but anyway i hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please don't forget to
hit the like button you can help support
uh hazel and everything that's going on
by going to patreon.com huge thank you
to everyone
who does help uh support this project
and everything that i'm doing here on
youtube
wouldn't be possible without you guys so
i really do appreciate all of your help
um this whole game industry is week
you'll be able to catch all the past
live streams over there on patreon as
well as see
hazeldev which is like the 3d c-sharp
scripting full-on editor version of
hazel
that is progressing much more quickly
than this thank you guys for watching
next time i think we're gonna make a
start on serialization which is gonna be
pretty exciting
so that we can actually construct a
scene and then save it so
exciting stuff coming soon see you guys
later goodbye
[Music]
you